[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
grande interview avec cette semaine
bérénice levée merci de nous consacrer
ce moment vous êtes philosophe de
formation mais philosophe aussi de
profession à servas c'est notre métier
on peut dire ça alors vous avez fait
bouillir libre beaucoup de livres de
pédagogie beaucoup de livres de
réflexion et l'analyse
alors moi je veux citer le plus connu
est celui que je connais moi le plus
c'est évidemment la théorie de la
théorie du genre chez grasset il paraît
d'ailleurs un livre de poche il est paru
en livre de poche ya pas très longtemps
c'est un livre qui a fondé votre image
forte qui est liée à la critique assez
violent que vous faites des mouvements
féministes alors on va forcément parler
d'ailleurs depuis ce livre vous avez
quand même persister dans votre
détermination le crépuscule des idoles
progressiste s'était également en partie
contre le contre le féminisme c'était
aussi un procédé intellectuelle je pense
que vous serez pas d'accord avec ce que
je dis mais comme je suis pas philosophe
j'ai le droit de le dire et puis l'année
dernière libérons-nous du féminisme une
bonne fois pour toutes je vous avais
failli ajouter à voix basse une défense
de la france pays de la galanterie du
libertinage aux édition de
l'observatoire si je voulais faire de la
provocation
vous cherchez le public des hommes là
quelque part oui allons partir va
d'ailleurs un des chapitres s'intitule
messieurs ne nous laissez pas seuls avec
les femmes
vaughn en effet en effet c'est bon vous
soient écoutés nous ont suivis bien vous
voir alors après une période
exceptionnelle mais les femmes aussi à
des femmes aussi bien sûr alors à je le
disais après une période
exceptionnellement de bras pendant
laquelle la france a été paralysée et
quand on sort du coma parce qu'on était
dans un coma artificiel
on a besoin de prendre un peu de hauteur
et on se tourne vers à faire un
philosophe
parce que pendant trois mois on a quand
même été inondés par les médecins les
experts les scientifiques les hommes
politiques
beaucoup d'économistes des journalistes
mais pas de philosophes pas tuer en
dehors de ceux qui ont leur rond de
serviette sur les plateaux de télévision
je pense à luc ferry ou à michel houel
on serait très médiatique à quoi peut
servir un philosophe dans la société
d'aujourd'hui a je crois poser la
question du sens du sens de ce que nous
faisons des choix que nous avons fait de
la société dans laquelle nous vivons de
l'interroger justement là le propre du
philosophe c'est déjà de savoir poser
des questions nous vivons assailli de
réponse de réponse immédiate et donc
c'est d'arriver à problématiser à mettre
en question les enjeux actuels
donc je crois que nous avons en effet un
rôle à jouer pour forer plus profond que
que la surface des shows justement ne
pas être dans l'actualité immédiate mais
d'essayer de voir l'idée de l'homme qui
se joue au travers des des parties que
nous avons pris depuis les années 60 70
c'est le thème sur lequel je travaille
actuellement je pense que un modèle de
société est à bout de souffle et que
nous avons en effet besoin de repenser
le les le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
je crois vraiment que nous vivons d'une
idée de l'homme qui est dégradée et
dégradante pour l'homme en son humanité
j'aime a cité un verre de saint john
perse qui dit et de l'homme quand donc
sera-t-il question je crois que cette
question nous n'avons pas trop posé et
que à présent il faut la prendre à bras
le corps et donc de savoir quelle
société nous voulons pour quel homme
et surtout quels rapports nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
nous sommes dans une idéologie de la
liberté sans limite et j'aimerais qu'on
pense l'homme comme un obligé du monde
comment peut-on simplement définir la
théorie du genre est ce que c'est
est-ce que
c'est la négation des différences entre
entre les hommes et les femmes entre la
sexualité masculine et la sexualité
féminine ou est-ce qu'il ya autre chose
alors ce qui est capital dans la théorie
du genre
c'est précisément la substitution du mot
sexe par jean c'est le coeur même de
leur pensée est de considérer que la
différence des sexes est une pure
construction sociale qu'il n'ya pas
d'ancrage naturelles ou biologiques à la
différence des sexes
il ne nie pas que sur le plan biologique
il y a une différence mais cela est s
demeure sans conséquence sur les vies
que nous menons si vous voulez il ya une
façon très simple de comprendre l'enjeu
de la théorie du genre
simone de beauvoir dit on ne naît pas
femme on le devient
les théoriciens du genre 10
simone de beauvoir est resté comme en
retrait par rapport à sa propre
intuition
si on ne naît pas femme pourquoi le
deviendrions-nous si bien que nous
pouvons jouer de toutes les identités
puisque n'ont qu'un ancrage dans la
nature aucun ancrage dans la biologie et
bien jouant de tous les sexes de toutes
les sexualités etienne et eric fassin un
des grands introducteur de la théorie du
genre en france dit le travesti et notre
vérité à tous c'est à dire que nous qui
considérons que parce que nous naissons
dans un corps de femme
et bien cela à quelques conséquences au
contraire sur nos traître et que on
s'habille en femme est bien en réalité
pour les théoriciens du genre nous
jouerions ce rôle que la société
exclusivement la société nous a assignés
donc si vous voulez c'est un pur
constructivisme un pur artifice ya
l'isthme et leur conviction est que si
après tout nous n'étions pas assigné à
une sexualité et à une identité sexuelle
nous
jorion de toutes ces identités donc il
faut libérer les individus de la nature
de la biologie et de la société dans ce
mouvement live sur des conflits pouvoir
ce sont des conflits de lobby on a le
lobby gay qui s'était formée qui c'est
c'est tout le mouvement de qui
revendique la stricte égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes sur le plan
économique sur le plan social sur le
plan des salaires sur le plan
d'entreprise
il ya beaucoup de politique derrière il
ya quand même beaucoup de politiques
tout à fait à oui de toute façon le
point de départ au point de départ ce
sont des lesbiennes qui reproche cela aa
à à simone de beauvoir
effectivement c'est une
indifférenciation complète des rôles
sexués c'est pourquoi je crois vraiment
qu'il faut rendre sa légitimité son
fondement à la nature parce que nous
avons bien il y à bien un étayage un
ancrage dans le données biologiques bon
j'aime à dire inspirées par anna rentes
que nous naissons femmes et nous le
devenons parce que évidemment qu'il y a
il y à du jeu c'est à dire que on
compose aussi notre propre féminité on
ne se plie pas à tout et n'importe quel
cas non mais il y a à la base un un
fondement naturel qu'est ce qui explique
cette énergie que vous mettez cet
engagement critiques contre le féminisme
à actuelle parce que parce que vous
mettez beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup de
détermination
oui je me bats je mets de l'énergie
parce que je considère que nous sommes
les héritiers d'une civilisation qui a
composé une partition absolument
magnifique sur se donner de la nature
qui est la différence des sexes et je ne
peux pas admettre que on se comporte
comme des éléphant dans un magasin de
porcelaine
c'est fragile ce que la civilisation
française à
conçue formés sur cette différence des
sexes tout ce jeu se sait délicatesse et
ses nuances et bien de les voir ainsi
alors qu'elle j'ignore tout en
définitive justement de ce qu'il y à de
savoureux dans la partition écrite par
la france de les voir ainsi se comporter
mais c'est pourquoi je ne sais par
absolument pas mon combat contre le
féminisme de mon combat contre toutes
les idoles du progressisme je suis
absolument accablé de voir que des
ignorants en définitive profitent de
l'idéologie et de l'ignorance
généralisée pour intenter un procès à
notre civilisation
bernis vous pouvez pas nier m cette
civilisation là elle a créé au ce fait
comme quand on arrive aux frontières de
l'économie aux sphères de l'économie de
la vie sociale des inégalités flagrantes
1 en matière de solaire en matière de
condition de lui dans toutes les
civilisations
alors j'ai du mal à parler de domination
c'est à dire que la domination c'est
véritablement un rapport de tyrannie il
y a eu effectivement une certaine
relégation des femmes
oui mais les femmes ont eu quand même du
pouvoir peut-être la coulisse mais on ne
peut pas nier que nous sommes dans une
civilisation ni mon histoire des
religions par exemple michel onfray que
vous connaissez bien
il raconte que dieu a créé adam le
premier et puis comme intention de
billets il a créé il a créé la femme
pour tous qu'ils s'amusent
non oui mais alors saint louis mais
c'est ça ne n'épuise absolument pas ce
qui se joue dans la différence sexuelle
telle qu'elle est posée par la bible au
contraire alors là je vous recommande et
je recommande à anne aux anneaux
à tous la lecture d'un petit
chef-d'oeuvre justement qui est le
journal d'adam et d'eve demain ceux de
mark twain qui est un chef-d'oeuvre
justement à la fois il se découvre dans
leur différence et se comprennent comme
comme différent que justement mais avec
un t1 des et ils ne peuvent plus se
passer malgré tout l'un de l'autre
donc il y as complémentarité entre les
deux sexes que l'un et l'autre ne soit
pas substituables c'est une chose
après je ne nie absolument pas le fait
que jusque dans les années 60 si ma
mémoire est bonne
la femme a besoin pourrait effectivement
avoir une indépendance économique de
l'autorisation du du mari donc je ne ne
n'occulte pas cela mais je ne je ne veux
pas que nous les lui ions notre
civilisation un rapport de domination
cette notion de domination nous a rendus
inaccessibles à toutes les nuances
toutes les finesses du jeu entre les
sexes mais pas simplement entre les
sexes se regarder maintenant c'est entre
l'homme et l'animal
nous ne saurions dans des rapports de
domination
c'est vous savez c'est cette grande
grille de lecture qui a été introduite
par les michel foucault et autres et qui
a appauvri notre intelligence du réel
dont vous avez vu arriver la théorie du
genre à l'éducation nationale quand vous
avez vu arriver la tentation de dana
donald en apprendre les prêts émis sous
les concepts aux enfants aux aides à des
ados ou à des pré ados vous avez dû
sauter en l'air dans cette âme et en
effet c'est ce que j'explique dans mon
livre sur la théorie du genre pendant
très longtemps je ne me suis absolument
pas intéressé et puis un jour mon neveu
rentre de l'école avec un ouvrage à lire
et dont il devait
réaliser la fiche de lecture le jour où
j'ai voulu m'habiller en fille ce livre
était un concentré de la théorie du
genre
et là je me suis dit il se passe quelque
chose d'autant que c'était
antérieurement aux prescriptions de du
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
était najat vallaud belkacem
c'est à dire avant les abécédaires du
genre et là j'ai compris que les
professeurs se faisaient eux-mêmes les
instigateurs de ces postulants ils
apprenaient à l'enfant à se détacher du
données biologiques et à croire que tout
était absolument construction historique
et c'est effectivement à partir de ce
moment-là que j'ai mené l'enquêté que
j'ai voulu savoir de quoi il retournait
et que et donc ensuite il ya eu toute la
polémique sur les abécédaires du genre
mais avant justement vous avez cette
fameuse discussion autour du fait que la
théorie du genre n'existerait pas bien
sûr qu'une telle la théorie du genre
existent parce qu'il a fallu des
théoriciens de ce petit vocable
apparemment inoffensif qui est le mot
genre pour que la théorie du genre
s'élabore et devienne un instrument
prétendument d'intelligibilité des
oeuvres littéraires des rapports sociaux
etc
j'ai vous citer le nom de trois
personnalités très connues et vous allez
me demander quelle est votre lecture de
la façon dont radio a été reçue à la
fois par les journalistes et part et par
l'opinion publique
la première c'est parti stein le
producteur de cinéma américain qui est
aujourd'hui en prison pour des raisons
qu'on sait tous et qui a servi de
détonateur au mouvement mis tout le
deuxième c'est bertrand cantat le
chanteur de noir désir qui a quand même
parce ont assassiné sa compagne marie
trintignant
et puis le troisième c'est dsk dsk qui a
brisé sa carrière politique est
quasiment un candidat et même président
de la république quand il a été pris par
des frasques sexuelles au sofitel de new
york doute vous connaissez ces trois
personnages ils ont été traités très
différemment par là par la presse et par
l'opinion publique
c'est une question d'époque c'est une
question d'évolution non non c'est alors
oui alors bon on va tout de suite allé à
bertrand content mais sans tuer parce
que c'est absolument c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est un homme de
gauche
si bien qu effectivement et bertrand
cantat est un homme de gauche et les
grandes consciences de gauche était fort
gêné justement d'avoir à se dresser
contre ce personnage qu'elle avait tant
aimée et qui est de tous les combats
parce que il
il est anti raciste il est estampillé de
toutes les bonnes causes
donc par rapport à bernard cantat les
militants féministes sont quand même mal
à l'aise avec dsk il me semble alors là
évidemment que la fièvre quand même est
monté
mais ce que j'ai pu j'ai essayé de
comprendre pourquoi les choses n'avaient
pas autant prix qu'avec weinstein parce
que on était dans un même cas de figure
après tout un homme blanc puissant riche
juif donc bon bien sûr hétérosexuels
il avait absolument tout pour être la
cible l'immense différence c'est que
entre l'allèle l'époque où l' affaire
dsk se déclenche et l'époque lunch times
entre temps il y a eu cet essor ce
développement des réseaux sociaux et
notamment ceux qui n'existaient pas du
temps de dsk c'était le fameux système d
hashtag est donc je crois que la chose
aurait peut-être pris un pardon si il y
avait eu déjà toute cette structure qui
avait pu se déclencher
je crois que c'est c'est à cela que l'on
doit cette différence de traitement
voilà je j'ai tendance à interpréter
ainsi les choses
après il est évident que
dans la mesure où weinstein était un
personnage américain peut-être que cela
il n'aura plus plus large a cédé le
milieu du cinéma aussi mais pour moi ce
qui a été décisif c'est vraiment le
l'intervention des réseaux sociaux et
donc je le redis l'avènement des hashtag
il est donc vous vous m'expliquer que la
raison profonde pour lesquelles le
traitement infligé à un dsk et et celui
adamson était différent à cause du
développement des réseaux sociaux sur
les réseaux sociaux qui ont servi
concept de caisse de résonance
ah oui oui pour le fait justement que ce
soit absolument la grande international
des féministes il fallait les réseaux
sociaux parce que souvenez vous quand
même au moment de l' affaire dsk il y a
eu des tribunes venant des états unis
pour accuser la france et sa
bienveillance à l'endroit des mâles
donc on a eu la polémique entre les
américaines les féministes américaines
et le féminisme à la française
donc il y a eu des tentatives mais les
choses n'ont pas prise parce qu'il n'y
avait pas ce relais des réseaux sociaux
on s'oriente bien quoi en vous écoutant
vers une société très puritaine très
très très coincé même si par ailleurs il
ya quand même des choses qu'il faut
corriger les comportements qu'il faut
qu'il faut assouplir et des inégalités
qu'il faut réduire
on s'oriente vers une cité ceux ci
étaient très peu tolérante
oui alors attention quand même à ne pas
accorder trop de crédit au discours
victimaire
les femmes ne sont pas non plus on a
l'impression que les hommes sont d'une
violence extrême et qu'il n'existe plus
que cela attention quand même à
l'ampleur que les médias tendent à
donner à certains événements à certains
épisodes
alors oui puritaine au sens où le désir
est criminalisé le désir que ou même
même indépendamment du désir simplement
le fait que l'homme soit sensible aux
charmes féminins
et rendu suspect ce mot j'aime à le
répéter mais ce mot de sexisme là aussi
il faut s'en méfier terriblement parce
que il vise à incriminer toute
perception toute pensée et toute
séduction que peut exercer la différence
des sexes dès lors que vous pensez la
différence entre un homme et une femme
vous tombez sous le coup de cette
accusation d'être sexiste
donc c'est une façon là aussi d'empêcher
simplement ne serait-ce que la
perception
alors donc puritaine oui dans la mesure
où il y a cette hantise du désir du
désir masculin
et puis je leur dis mais c'est une
négation aussi de la complexité de ce
qui se joue entre un homme et une femme
et c'est infiniment plus complexe que ce
que les féministes voudrait nous faire
croire
j'invite sur la question justement du du
désir en pensant à la ferme à ce n'est
fait à d'autres que l'allemagne neuf
jeunes excuses en aucune façon un mais
la seule chose c'est que je voudrais que
l'on ait conscience de de la complexité
pari du jeu aussi que alors après
l'homme est tenu absolument de se tenir
deux de se sentir responsable est
justement de savoir le jeu qu'une
adolescente de 14 ans peut jouer mais
j'invite à relire certaines pages de
colette sur sur ce désir que la jeune
fille m a déclenché à provoquer je le
redis l'homme doit savoir se retenir
mais il n'empêche que l'on ne peut pas
le faire se contenter de ce scénario de
l'oie blanche et du prédateur vous
auriez pu me donner l'exemple aussi de
de polanski et la façon dont il a été
accueilli y ont notamment de son dernier
film ah oui alors plus encore justement
vous avez raison je pense d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus à polanski
parce que là on est vraiment au coeur
d'une d'une obsession fin de quelque
chose qui qui qui est purement
idéologique qui est un combat purement
idéologique et oui tout à fait tout à
fait vous avez dit dans le figaro il n'y
a pas très longtemps c'est pas une crise
sanitaire c'est une crise de sociabilité
c'était un déficit de sociable vous
expliquez ça oui alors si vous voulez
bon bien sûr que c'est une crise
sanitaire mais qui est rendue plus
cruelle encore parce qu'elle induit
justement dans les relations sociales
c'est à dire que par le alors cette
distanciation par alors le port du
masque qui qui va complètement à
contre-courant d'un des fondements de
notre société qui est de vivre à visage
découvert et surtout si vous voulez le
visage et le lieu même de l'expressivité
le lieu de la singularité est évidemment
que je pense aux magnifiques analyse de
de levinas qui montre très bien que le
visage de l'autre c'est aussi ce qui
vous institut en être de responsabilité
il y a une une fragilité qui est propre
à l'individu et que son visage porte
précisément parce que c'est la partie la
plus dénudée la plus exposée
1 vous vous ne dissimulez rien de ce que
vous êtes
ou alors justement vous fait vous vous
prenez soin d expression que vous livrer
au public mais un si vous voulez c'est
véritablement quelque chose qui qui met
en question tous ces rapports que nous
avions finement tissés au fil des
siècles parce que alors si il y à une
civilisation qui a le génie de la
sociabilité c'est bien la civilisation
française
alors évidemment qu'il y avait en plus
la la la
non fréquentation des lieux de
sociabilité que sont les cafés les
restaurants
tous ces espaces où précisément nous
entretenons la relation aux autres aux
amis aux proches et donc tout cela et
est hypothéquée remis en question par
ces conditions parler les conditions
imposées par l'épidémie est ce que est
ce que le fait de tout bloquer de tout
arrêter
justement les rapports de travail les
machines économique les rapports de
fiabilité est ce que c'est la première
fois dans l'histoire que l'ensemble de
la planète s'arrête comme ça un bisou à
le dire faisant dévier arrêté est ce que
ça valait la peine
finalement pour préserver et on ne sait
pas combien de vies humaines doit faire
autrement oui je n'en vois là moi je
mets en revanche ce que cela met en
lumière ces l'impéritie du gouvernement
et du pouvoir parce que on doit le
répéter c'est précisément parce que il
n'y avait pas de test il n'y avait pas
de masque que le confinement a pris
cette forme extrême arrêté malgré tout
deux de d'occulter cet élément
évidemment que le confinement n'est pas
propre à la france
les formes qu'il a prises le sont malgré
tout alors parce que nous n'avions pas
les moyens de de tester suffisamment et
donc de confiner les personnes qui le
justifiait ça c'est bon
le président peut toujours nié qu'il n'y
a pas eu de problème de masse qu'il y a
eu un problème de masques bon et canto
on a eu et qui plus est des mois pour se
préparer puisque nous n'avons pas été
les premiers affectés
pour terminer je vous disais en
commençant qu'il n'y avait pas forcément
à cette philosophe parce qu'il nous
amène quelques fois de la hauteur de vue
et un peu de un peu de sagesse ou de
relativité
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous vous
donneriez comme conseil à un jeune pour
qu'il devienne ou qui prennent goût à la
philosophie parce que on en manque
finalement qu'est ce que vous lui diriez
pour l'intéressé axe à un moment où lui
ne s'adresse pas aux digital et à la
start up qui va lui permettre de faire
fortune oui alors moi c'est très simple
je pense que il y a
d'abord parce que j'ai longtemps
enseigné en terminale et je sais que
j'étais capable quand même de
transmettre et partager cette passion de
la philosophie
je crois que ce qui fonde un esprit
philosophique ce qui fait naître un
esprit philosophique c'est vraiment la
passion de d'interroger de comprendre la
passion du sens est à dire ne pas
simplement être dans l'action dans le
faire mais de toujours s'interroger sur
ce que nous faisons
je crois que quand on contracte la
passion de comprendre
elle ne nous quittent plus et si vous
voulez c'est ça la promesse que les
grandes oeuvres de la philosophie et
aussi de la littérature et celle de
l'art là on en revient à mon travail
initial sur un arabe nous nous réserve
c'est que vous gagnez toujours en
intelligence de la condition humaine de
ce que nous vivons et je crois que il y
a en tout être humain la page et 7,7 ce
plaisir delà du sens
en fait un être humain
et est un être mutilé s'il ne satisfait
pas 7
vous avez c'est une très belle phrase de
montagne nous sommes nés à quêter la
vérité par vérité il entend justement le
sens et je crois que c'est là notre
tâche que de permettre à tout être
humain de d'abord de sentir qu'il a en
lui même cette passion et ensuite de la
forme et la cultiver au contact des
grandes oeuvres
merci beaucoup on retrouve les mictions
en rediffusion sur l'antenne en replay
aussi bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux
et sur le site internet de france.fr
merci à vous disent merci à tous a très
bien merci
[Musique]